now welcome back he is a singer actor
host dancer and part of our City's past
and present Donny Osmond a legend in
Show Business and he just announced his
extended residency at Harrah's I had a
chance to sit down with him and kind of
pull back the curtain a little it kicks
off our Donny Osmond week and here's
what he had to say about his show
[Applause]
Donny Osmond the ultimate showman
gracing the stage since the age of five
by seven he was already a Vegas fixture
I've Waited All My Life Heather to do a
show like this because it's all
inclusive everything I've done and
somehow we squeeze it into a 90-minute
show that's six Decades of show business
I mean I keep pinching myself for the
fact that this is my show and I'm on the
strip and we've gotten awards for it and
it's it's just a it's a dream come true
what you can expect a performance to
rival any headliner what you might not
expect a wrap it All Began back in Utah
I was four years old started singing
with my brothers and the sound was like
gold so my folks took a leap and said
what the hey we got to get these
monsters out to California and it goes
faster and faster and faster 10 minutes
long took me three months to memorize
this thing Donnie says the show is an
anthology of his life so far including
about 15 minutes where the audience gets
to request songs how does that go I mean
65 albums how do you I can't remember
what I ate for breakfast it's a
technical nightmare it works 99 of the
time it's all ages and Donnie relish is
the fact that he has fans from every
stage in his ever evolving career a lot
of youngsters come here and they know me
as Captain Shang
from the Disney movie Mulan it was like
this is a whole new generation of uh
followers
from Osmond Mania to Donnie and Marie to
this the longevity of his career
certainly not lost on him and he says
he's loving this time in his life I'm
very fortunate very lucky that I can
continue on it's such a fun show Heather
I enjoy getting on stage every night
[Music]
and you definitely want to check it out
stay tuned though coming up in our six
o'clock hour you're going to have a
chance to win four tickets and a VIP
experience to see Donny Osmond caller
number eight will win we will put that
number up for you like I said in our six
o'clock hour so stay tuned and if you
have a little puppy love you might be
able to see him in person